We can also can cross configuration with case based reasoning.
Both configuration and case based reasoning are typically applied to routine
design problems, problems of the kind that we've often encountered in the past.
Gives a configuration, we start with a prototypical concept,
then assign values to all the variables as we saw in this chair example.
In case of case-based reasoning we start with the design of
a specific chair that we had designed earlier. Look at its variables and
tweak it as needed to satisfy this constraint so the current problem.
Case-based reasoning assumes that we already designed our other chairs, and
we have stored examples of the chairs for designing the memory.
Configuration assumes, that we already designed enough chairs so
that we can in fact extract the plan. When a specific problem is presented to
an IA agent, the IA agent, if it is going to use the method of configuration,
is going to call upon the plan obstruction hierarchy and then
start defining plans. If the AI agent uses the method of case based reasoning,
then it'll go into the case memory, retrieve the closest matching case, and
then start tweaking the case. Little bit later we will see how an AI agent
select between different methods that were able to address the task. As we
have mentioned earlier in the course, the chemical periodic table was one of
the really important scientific discoveries. Similar to chemical periodic table,
we are trying to build a periodic table of intelligence.
Unlike the chemical periodic table which deals with balance electrons.
Our periodic table of intelligence, deals with tasks and methods.
In this particular course, we have considered both a large number of tasks,
configuration being one of them, as well as a large number of methods,
[UNKNOWN] instantiation and case-based reasoning being two of them.